okay let's talk about big political
issues I've been talking for a while on
the show about what I consider to be the
largest and most impactful issues for
the future of Homo sapiens and for our
ability to continue being political
activists macro issues what's an example
campaign finance reform okay the way
that we finance politics and elections
in the United States is a disaster and
whether you care about education or
public health or whatever campaign
finance reform is a massive massive meta
issue health care if people don't have
access to health care if people are
going bankrupt because of health care
expenses if people are sick and can't
get care you can't be an activist
if you're sick or focused on figuring
out how to afford the care that you need
so health care for everybody
massive meta issue voter
disenfranchisement this includes voter
ID voter suppression election fraud all
the stuff we talked about earlier on the
show today related to Carolinas and
North Carolina's ninth district that is
a major meta issue if people need to
vote to make their voices heard but
their votes aren't being counted that's
a real problem climate change if your
city is underwater if more people than
ever are dying from heat related illness
because of climate change etc etc it's
hard to be an activist for what you
believe in
I've also mentioned net neutrality and
media consolidation how we learn about
stuff is mostly through media and the
internet so that's really really
important I've also talked about ranked
choice voting to break the two-party
duopoly the Trump
White House has become extra obsessed
with one of those issues and that's
climate change and in fact they now are
going to create a group to refute the
consensus science of climate change this
is an initiative that started within the
National Security Council and the plan
is they're going to bring in scientists
who are effectively useful idiots for
the climate denier community they're
going to bring in scientists that
question for example this of
verity of climate impacts they're going
to bring in scientists that question the
degree to which humans are contributing
to the climate change reality on our
planet and they're actually being really
clever about how they're going to
structure it legally because initially
the plan was create an actual Federal
Advisory Committee that is this sort of
climate skeptic committee the problem
with that is that it would then fall
under the jurisdiction of what's called
the Federal Advisory Committee Act and
what that does is it puts in place some
ground rules for these committees
including that they have to have certain
open meeting requirements they have
reporting laws about what they're doing
and what's being discussed if you are
trying to create a propaganda group the
last thing you want is open meeting
requirements and mandatory reporting so
instead they're calling it a working
group working groups have none of those
requirements so we are not going to have
any idea what it is that they're doing
and the plan is to handpick people who
are just useful to denying the climate
science they're going to organize them
in a structure where there will be
minimal accountability no reporting
requirements now you might hear me say
this and wonder why do we care about
this Trump had this election integrity
Commission it folded without
accomplishing a damn thing some of those
business panels that Trump set up ended
up imploding very publicly when notable
CEOs including people like Elon Musk
bailed out because they said I can't
work with Donald Trump the difference is
that this ties directly to two really
important narratives for the
administration number one this is an
administration obsessed with pushing
outdated energy like coal Trump has
expressed multiple times he wants to
rehabilitate reinvigorate whatever the
term is the coal industry a panel like
this one with no sort of adult
supervision can work in very devious
ways to push coal to pushback against
auto efficiency standards to push back
against the development of all
turn ative green and renewable energies
this would have a real impact
potentially number two these are the
types of groups that end up gathering
position papers and bogus think-tank
pieces which later are cited as evidence
that there's actually a controversy on
the issue of climate when there isn't so
this is sort of twofold danger number
one this is a group that will have
almost no oversight because again
they're calling it a working group
rather than a federal committee it will
have direct value to dirty energy okay
this is a group that could directly help
to line the pockets of the dirty energy
purveyors and corporations and in the
longer term it'll also have this kind of
indirect propaganda value so this is
really really bad the goal is create
something that looks like official
disagreement between scientists so that
they can push the narrative that there
is a controversy we've talked about this
false false balance false neutrality
that we sometimes see in media where
despite the reality that more than 99.9
percent of climate scientists agree
about climate change you'll see a media
interview with two Talking Heads
one which agrees with the science and
one who disagrees
that's 50/50 even though the science is
ninety-nine point nine to 0.1 this type
of working group is going to allow them
to better foment those ideas of a
disagreement within the scientific
community which basically doesn't exist
even the Pentagon now says climate
change is one of the biggest threats it
is a national security issue to the
military even when the military is
evaluating and considering operations
climate change is now a major
consideration in terms of how they're
going to carry forward some of these
operations and tasks around the world
this is a mechanism to create just a
little bit of doubt just a little bit
longer to try to foment some sort of
plausible deniability around continuing
to push dirty energy continuing to push
policy that is really
from people who benefit from that dirty
energy ignoring the as of now undeniable
red alert
realities of what it is that we are
doing to the planet into our country
very very dangerous
not very much reported on and we are
going to continue making an effort to
tell you about a lot of this less
scandalous less sexy stuff that is often
not being reported at all but is going
to have a huge long-term impact on us on
the next generation and the generation
after that one of the day's sponsors is
privacy comm slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy comm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
five
towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link